pixel has always been a leader in
smartphone Innovation and we take it as
a compliment when others in the industry
follow our lead like the always-on
display and at a glance introduced with
pixel 2 and there's night sight which
launched with pixel 3 and
astrophotography and we introduced car
crash detection three years ago
pixel 7 pixel 7's Pro's front camera
uses our Advanced machine learning
models for face recognition to power
face unlocked iPhone 10 your iPhone is
locked until you look at it and it
recognizes you we call this
face ID we're introducing cinematic blur
to the pixel camera in iPhone 13 brings
a brand new feature cinematic mode
starting at 2X
super resume crops pixel 7 Pro's main 50
megapixel camera using a high resolution
mode to provide a 12.5 megapixel 12
megapixels of the new sensor to deliver
a full resolution photo and 4K video
with Optical quality
yeah I kind of just love how tech
companies just throw subtle shots at
each other on stage even though we all
know at this point they're just copying
each other in a giant Circle till we
have the same features across everything
anyway today was Google's event and we
got our first look at Impressions and
our Hands-On time with the Google pixel
7 and pixel 7 Pro and the pixel watch
which is really interesting and we also
got a preview of a really interesting
look at the new pixel tablet so this
video is everything you need to know
about all that stuff so the phones
there's a big phone and a small phone
again the pixel 7 and the pixel 7 Pro
they very much look like the pixel 6 now
that it's an established recognizable
visor identity but this time the visor
is metal instead of glass and I don't
love it but I also don't hate it like I
guess I was one of the few people that
really got to liking the glass visor but
I will say this time it is one
continuous piece of metal all the way
around with no seam and that is better
than before and it just feels really
well built but you can also see the
pixel 7 visor is matte while the pixel 7
Pro visor is glossy which I can already
tell I'm gonna get this 7 Pro covered in
fingerprints also I'm just going to say
I miss accented color power buttons just
throwing that out there anyway no other
real design surprises here but then on
the inside there is an updated set of
specs so there they are you can pause
this if you need to but basically the
bigger phone has a telephoto lens more
RAM and a bigger battery and a bigger
higher res ltpo display that's the deal
but here's something I noticed I wasn't
really mentioned even out loud during
the keynote which is the pixel 7 display
is flat again and you can see the cut
out at the top for the new Ultra wide 11
megapixel selfie camera that they both
share it's pretty sweet but the pixel 7
Pro display curves over the edges a bit
less than before it's just a subtle
curve now I'm really happy to see that
but then as I mentioned in the last
video which was about the iPhone 14 plus
and benchmarks and how the big General
Benchmark improvements are probably
going to be pretty slight I was more
interested just to see features just new
interesting features that they enable on
these new phones right and we got some
and they range from kind of cool seen
that already all the way to possibly
incredible so yeah I'm going to keep my
eye out on the overall performance of
this next Generation tensor G2 chip
efficiency smoothness all that but it
also enables a few things a new
cinematic video mode which basically
appears to be doing the same thing
Apple's new cinematic mode does which is
track subjects and artificially blur
backgrounds it also enables transcribed
audio messages right in the Google
messages app so if someone sends you a
voice memo you don't have to find a
place to listen to it you can just read
it in text form and it makes night sight
twice as fast it enables Face Unlock
from just the new selfie camera and it
should be able to do all this with 20
lower power consumption than the first
tensor chip but the coolest feature to
me easily is unblur is what it's called
so so you have a picture that's slightly
blurry you know maybe your hands were
kind of shaky or it was slightly out of
focus or you just had a slow shutter
speed or something happened it's blurry
it's soft normally you throw photo out
but you don't have any other pictures of
that moment and it was just too perfect
and you kind of just want to save it or
fix it so you can open that picture on
the pixel 7 or 7 Pro and you hit that
button and the tensor chip goes to work
and it basically fixes the picture it
uses AI it recognizes subjects and
sharpens things up and it does a really
good job you can see a before and after
here of some of the pre-loaded photos I
was trying at the event and they are
genuinely impressive and the cherry on
top is so you have to have a pixel 7 or
7 Pro to do this for now but you can do
this with any picture in your entire
Google photos Library any photo you've
ever taken or even any photo you just
save or have on your phone anything I
can see people like remastering old
Polaroids or like 30 year old yearbook
photos just whatever else is in your
library that you want to save
seems pretty cool I'm going to be
testing it for the full review to see
how well it actually works with
non-presupplied photos but I was
impressed but then really mostly other
changes that were interesting about
these phones came in a camera department
on the pro phone so there's a new
ultrawide with autofocus just on the pro
phone that is 21 wider and should be
able to take some pretty decent macro
photos now with these Focus pixels and
there's a new 5x telephoto camera that's
also huge 48 megapixels again and then
they've worked a lot of software magic
with making the in-between marks much
more usable so for example the 2x button
here will crop into the middle 12
megapixels of the main camera for a nice
clean Zoom sound familiar but then the
10x does the same thing so the 10x Zoom
is really just cropping into the middle
12 megapixels of the 5x telephoto camera
so again hopefully a nice clean zoom and
then a lot of super resume software
magic and hopefully sharpening the
photos of in between those numbers but
there's also haptic stops in the camera
UI to make it easy to hopefully hit
those nice Clean Magic numbers and they
also added a zoom preview thing for the
furthest extremes of Zoom like Samsung
did so now when you're taking those
super creeper shots at like 30X it'll be
nice and stable and easy to frame my
biggest question is did they price these
correctly because they went with the
same prices as last year which is 5.99
for the small phone and 8.99 for the big
one
which okay it's the same I have a
feeling 300 is going to feel like a big
gap again like this is what we were
saying last year for 300 extra dollars
over the small phone you're getting
bigger screen nicer battery and a
telephoto camera
and that's kind of it this year it feels
like a tiny bit more it's screen battery
and then like a whole Pro camera system
with a better ultrawide and a better
telephoto with lots of Zoom stuff
but is that enough
300 I I don't know we'll see I just have
a feeling that the the seven will feel
like a good deal and then a 7 Pro will
feel like a tougher sell again but then
we also finally got to see the Google
pixel watch this is the thing that's
been kind of hyped a lot I got to spend
a little less time with it but I'm very
interested in reviewing this particular
watch so this might be a hot take but I
think they did a b-plus job on the
design I think it's really nice uh the
full circle is great it's just one size
which is pretty small and very
lightweight there's three colors black
silver and gold and definitely doesn't
look like a computer on your wrist like
some others can it can be a super
inconspicuous little puck of a smart
watch there's just two buttons the crown
which can also scroll and then a button
right above it and the way the watch
bands connect to the watch is pretty
neat it's a little bit finicky to me at
first but I suspect it just takes some
getting used to and the result is just
this super seamless look with no lugs
where it looks like the band just kind
of pops out the top and the bottom of
this circle now here's why I say B plus
and not a plus
bezels and battery so they curve the
glass right over all the edges and kept
the UI mostly black which is really
thoughtful because most of the time
especially in lower lighting it looks
like it's basically a seamless display
on your wrist most of the backgrounds
are black most of the UI elements look
like they're designed around sort of
fading in and not overlapping the edges
too much and even when they do overlap
they have this nice little gradient even
the flashlight app has a fade all the
way around so you don't really think too
hard about the bezel it's smart but if
you catch the Light just right or maybe
you're outside a lot then yeah you can
see the bezel which is clearly not the
smallest thing in the world okay fine
but I'm actually a little bit more
worried about battery life so they set
on stage up to 24 hours of battery which
you know knowing these companies is
probably generous like that's probably
maybe best case scenario without the
always-on display maybe one workout and
I mean this watch is truly tiny it's
very Compact and light like there's just
no way you can have a huge battery in it
but I think it's a good idea to
subscribe to be among the first to see
the full review when it goes live and I
get a chance to really test it
functionality wise though it is very
much a Fitbit Smart Watch like I think
it might be more of a Fitbit than a lot
of people were expecting but you know
smart watch wise it does all the normal
stuff notifications custom watch faces
Google pay with wallet Google Maps
directions Google Assistant to set
timers play some music Etc it's wear OS
but then it's Fitbit for all the fitness
stuff which there's plenty of so if
you've used a Fitbit you already know
about the workouts and mindfulness
content and health metrics and sleep
tracking and a sleep score and it has
some really high frequency heart rate
monitoring one reading every single
second but other than the specifically
the heart rate monitoring stuff it uses
the Fitbit app for all that stuff so not
Google Fit what happens to Google Fit
unclear actually but the watch comes
with six months of Fitbit premium for
free and that you just interact with all
this data just like it's a Fitbit so
yeah it's a it's a Fitbit smart watch or
it's a smart watch with Fitbit on top
for all the fitness stuff so it's 349
for the Wi-Fi only and 400 for cellular
so that means it's more expensive than
the Apple watch SE it's more expensive
than the Samsung Galaxy watch 5.
interesting let me know which one of
those smart watches you would consider
for that money but lastly we did get a
preview of the tablet another one but
this time it did it was basically just
one one really cool feature which is
that it docks to a magnetic speaker dock
and becomes basically a nest Hub Max and
I think this is brilliant most tablets
are just like around the house most of
the time and Google knows this so they
just built the ultimate house tablet I
guess I do think though that this is a
bit of a clue that this isn't going to
be a super high-end like iPad Pro Galaxy
Tab Pro super crazy premium like tablet
this is this is definitely not competing
with those like this thing will have a
10 inch screen single camera white
bezels it's like this thing's designed
for the 80 of tablets that just sit
around the house and don't do too much
like not the top few percent that are
doing Peak Performance and productivity
and media stuff I'm guessing and this is
pure speculation and you can quote this
I'm going to guess that this will be a
4.99 tablet like that's how I see this
and then you'll buy the doc extra but
we'll come back to this clip and see if
I was right but yeah stay tuned for the
reviews happy techtober thanks for
watching this one
and I'll catch you guys later
peace
[Music]